[Music]
i'm danny chu and i'm the million-mile
man
i want to ride bicycles a million miles
over my lifetime
i set the million-mile goal uh sometime
when i was in college i just fell in
love with cycling and about the same
time i created a ride in pittsburgh
called the dirty dozen
i found out that the longer the race was
the better i did and i won the uh the
race across america in 1996 and 1999.
so i was
doing one of my trips that i do where i
try to do a thousand miles in one week i
just got dizzy or something and veered
off to the left and i'm in the ditch
before i know it and i can't move
anything below my chest i can't get up
to to suddenly have that freedom where i
can go any i can go anywhere my legs
will take me and have it taken away in a
second i was
it was tough to take
i mean when i was in that hospital i was
very depressed those few weeks after the
accident
so i'm basically about seven and a half
months out from the accident now and
my condition is amazingly better than
obviously compared the day after the
accident i expected to take at least a
year to get my arms big enough to be
able to do a decent speed on the hand
cycle i still need about 210 000 miles
but if i can get up to where i can
average 200 miles a week on a hand siren
i could still get a million miles 21
years from now i'd be 75 then and i hope
to live to be at least that that's great
i'm very proud of you though you've come
a long way
when you have a horrible spinal cord
issue like that you have two choices you
can just sort of crawl up and you know
be miserable or
think of it as a new challenge to tackle
which is what i've done
as a paralyzed person you're stuck in a
wheelchair most of the time that you're
awake
but at least when i'm on the hand cycle
you're not in a wheelchair you're like a
machine like a bicycle so there's a
sense of freedom there that you get away
from the wheelchair and it's really nice
the million mile goal take me a little
bit longer than i originally planned
but i feel like i owe it to my fans and
the people that support me that i have
to keep going and you know chasing this
million mile dream
you